[Music]
they're um quarantining together
which gets sloppy
i'm sick of this here covered how much
does the latest crisis
actually impact this family the connors
it's a part of every episode but it
doesn't overwhelm
every episode it wouldn't be the conners
without a financial crisis
so we still got that going for us
ah there she is our american
hero blackish is also tackling the
pandemic
during their new season tracee ellis
ross's character rainbow is working on
the front lines
masked up hey now how are the votes of
you doing
in real life anthony has grown out his
beard and i got the
whole throw going on i've also grown out
my back hair
but we don't ever show that on the show
but tracy combs it every day
not only as she combs it she cornrows it
you know what that is tmi the
goldbergs are also back in action on abc
tonight
paying homage to the 1980 film airplane
surely you can't be serious if you don't
i'll have you arrested that's
not the line i am serious and don't call
me shirley
and get this the plane they filmed on
was the same one used in bridesmaids
which wendy mcclendon covey also starred
in
where she goes she'll take a seven and
seven you'll like it it's sweet
oh my god yeah more than
like when you don't understand how much
this means to me
that we have now found a way to tie this
in to our show